[Music]
about to start
hello everyone and welcome to ultimate
moves between team Randy and team Rex
the sing fields will battle against each
other and with also the top players in
the world including one and Gary
Kasparov and the moves matter but the
trash-talking makes it even better
and we're gonna jump now to our format
for this event there will be six games
six games played at a pace of five
minutes with a five second increment and
after five moves both teams will rotate
players and Gables will start every 20
minutes and for the matchups we'll have
team Randy and on his team will be
Fabiano Caruana Hikaru Nakamura
Vishwanath on Anand Levon Aronian Maxine
by Sheila grab a nice giri and Yan Nepal
machine and for Team Rex we will of
course have rights with Gary Kasparov
Magnus Carlsen ding Lauren Yaser Ceylon
Wesley so Sergei Kuryakin and chakra our
mama theorem well that indeed should be
an exciting event
I think that the players their players
who think that there are better trash
talkers than others they'll try to
confuse each other with the moves but we
will see who has the best game in this
contest well let me introduce the two
players they need no introduction well
first of all the man of the hour
Rex Sinquefield to the stage Rex you may
come on up
and his son Randy Singh field he's got a
lot of hate right now from the teams
well let's start with you Rex
every year you have to do this every you
have to compete against your son I know
there's bragging rights what are your
thoughts about the contest this year I'm
surprised these guys even showed up you
guys just want to resign it's starting
already Randy I think you nicked him
last year from that mistake yeah I came
off a win last year so I'm feeling
pretty good pretty confident lose lots
of confidence here well I believe we
have a drawing of lots if I'm not
mistaken Chris Byrd international
arbiter will now draw lots to see who
gets white in the first game remember
there are six games as Magnus Carlsen
comes in and here we go who gets to
choose white so they take their places
gentlemen before they get started I'd
like to get a word from each of the
teams I'm going to start over here Gary
we haven't seen you welcome your
thoughts about this year last year I was
a losing side this year I hope it will
improve here next to me so how can we
lose a lot of confidence there I'm gonna
go over here and Fabiano your thoughts
on this contest well I think I just want
to give Gary an idea of what's gonna
happen next week
I will be playing in just 960 next week
the trash-talking begins early well with
that we're gonna start the matchup yeah
just quickly
it's 5+5 misery already said gentlemen
please do not shout out any moves to the
players you can trash talk all you want
but no hints please and then after every
after every five moves obviously we'll
move another player in and we'll just
keep going round until we get a result
you may get up and watch of course you
get around the board and see what's
going on if we start off with a boom
d-force
same hand or Andy watch out all right
already starting in the direction of a
Kings Indian Gary's favorite opening the
group so he is extremely excited in this
moment yes sir you're playing not
commentating it feels weird it does I
don't know why they recruited me I mean
I feel like I misplaced on the team but
I'll do my best
well you better than that stay on the
sidelines and now a capture on c5 a
critical moment in the game upon in my
opinion
to prevail eventually Magnus and Hikaru
Nakamura are now down Knight to c6 and
debate for your thoughts about this
position wasn't luck doing already very
well now a tricky position has it looks
like threats developing as white
[Music]
[Applause]
all right it looks like White has traded
in the check this one comes in and ding
Lauren we know just prevailed today
we'll see what his trash-talking skills
are like you're feeling about doing
stretch talking skills what do you think
about the position right now the 94 is
very good I think we she feels the
pressure he's your teammate how can you
be trapped on here today
no even when these planes again each
side is a bit for that they think an
excellent shape really
and Chuck we are your thoughts about the
game right now okay I don't like in
games this looks very good it looks very
good for her
Blackie's and LaVon comes in and c5
breaking open breaking open the position
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
he doesn't want to take you're feeling
about this Vichy I think you didn't see
anything else this one right now
looks like it's nice for fun guys what
should I be talking okay that's getting
tense right now
yeah well Blake is clearly better it was
the questions
one more move for ya so sir one
you're upon down those very big parlance
III know but look that pond restricts
the black Bishop if not for the former
bishop would have the whole day I do not
now the bishop is bad and we get a trade
on d4 Anisha are you feeling concerned
right now no I think we've done loans on
an outstanding job oh no it's always
good to give up upon when you are in
trouble now at least you know it's
obvious to everyone so plenty of time on
the clock for both sides 353 342
[Laughter]
Gary Ross your smile looks like an
artist right now the way
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's gonna take a little effort sure is
Russian team
[Music]
and who's gonna follow Randy and Rex
aren't gonna get back in it so what do
you think about that LaVon Randy has
shown that he's you know he's defending
and winning all kinds of positions so
we're so and and you know Gary is
hinting Greg's now so all right now the
sing fields are back in a tense moment
as they have to keep up the quality of
play I don't think the big moment in the
game right now has traded off for
critical pawn
[Music]
depakote Oh more trades
and all four of our eyes is become
impossible to win any coming nothing
well now the position is drawn they have
agreed to a draw one game done there's a
there's a little bit of controversy
breaking out right now who be aid was
winning by force I know that you make it
comment which is still fair alright
we'll have Chris Berger talk to the
players about making comments during the
game we'll get to reply on that one but
for the moment first game has ended in a
draw we will begin our next game in just
a few minutes guys how you feel about
that results Bobby yeah it was great I
mean Randy really pulled through he
defended a losing position and I have to
only make the final touch on the defense
which was really not difficult when I
played he takes a five dozen to
challenging all right we tie we're gonna
switch colors Rex will have a white
Randy will that black is we set up for
the next game
and we see this controversy already and
we're on one and by the way this is
supposed to be a friendly match
a little bit of negativity happening I
mean we were winning from start to
finish we had it in the bag and just at
the end there
you know bad advice from you know the
Devils on the other side persuaded Rex
to trade off his final pond and that
just really threw us off so we're very
upset with the other team for their
horrifying cheating and unsportsmanlike
conduct we're here ain't cheating and
unsportsmanlike conduct Negro now that I
think you know we were just discussing
things between our team you know it's
the heat of the moment so they were
shouting did you hear them shouting I
made I think the audience heard them
shouting I'm just a commentator you know
you can fill in that complaint
to file a complaint
you have to officially pay $500 in
advance all right it looks like enough
controversy we're gonna play our second
game I think we're ready for our second
game okay Randy you're behind the black
pieces
Rex is behind the white pieces that game
get a heated start switching sides so
team Rex and team's Randy you're both
switching sides now so go gentlemen and
gentlemen switching sides so you're on
the white side now so you go to this
side of the room same order as usual and
Rex sitting down getting ready Rex how'd
you feel about that first game it could
have gone better I screwed it up at the
end I should have taken my rook off eh
foul brought it back to the Kings side
do you think the other team cheated did
they influence you in any way no all
right well that says it all that does
that Randy your feelings about the first
game yeah I'm glad to get the first game
out of the way
now I can think a little more clearly
but I feel really good about the outcome
all right well we're game to Rex with
the white pieces Randy with the black
pieces and away we go
handshake in the clocks have started and
the game has begun
efore on the board the game has begun
gentlemen the game is in progress known
as a Spanish on the board ninety-six
castles
Rex's up d6 played by Randy and is
Magnus versus vichy we've seen this in
two World Championship matches and an
immediate capture on c6 by Magnus this
she likes nice apparently yeah nice
jumping into c6 back to my yards back to
my neighbour how you feeling about this
thing
all right they're in a very rich
position with a pawn structure for black
has changed dramatically and the change
of bishop or Knight
[Laughter]
9:05 is coming guys a lot of control
Ches in this game you're not used to
being in these positions put me a knight
our player MV ow what do you feel about
this now you have to go sit down and
play I'll be fine
it cannot go worse she will break defy
the venturi and so don't define a lot of
moves being thrown out of Fabi I don't
trust any of them I still am wondering
what Amish is doing name I know he was
told to trash-talk but seems like he's
part of the commentary team in I think
he's taking turns in a hole of us all
right well this position is rich alright
to understand what's going on Gary you
look intently right intense right now
are you liking this position for white
we're very good position the math right
max
it looks like both teams right now are
very big much considering this rich
position once he doesn't want to make
another move you'd like to get out of
here but a big time decision is white is
building this position quite nicely all
the poise pieces out black still needed
to develop some pieces super my
teammates has just given me a splendid
position I feel like I'm at a banquet
and with lavon on the other side of the
table my confidence has been soaring a
lot of time being spent on this move as
there's a big edge on the clock for
white and now mvl sitting down he said
he likes active positions and e5 the
break is on the board water supply
forcing yasser who loves pawns not
pieces what does the engine say
and he's taken the piece but look there
goes the bishop and are you trying to
mimic Magnus right now you have to stay
quiet we don't want any fights
sacrifices Queen put the Rex Sinquefield
there lucky for you Rex my only Grand
Master's can't count so let's get them
see you back
alright somehow there was some confusion
there as to whose move it was a what
move number and right now even though
down material it looks like clock is
back in business
a mate threat followed by a nasty boom
suddenly black is in business yeah sir
Sir one
ouch are completely but Wesley asking ya
sir to come back and finish this
disaster of a position well it looks
like they're still fighting chances yes
[Music]
there are no trades yeah so the
attraction I made the wrong 95 was a
winning move it was my original idea but
I thought I saw something clever all
right trouble for the white pieces right
now but you know anything could happen
when the sink feels it back down so
white has to survive at least for now
from trouble for why only LaVon could
have set it up so perfectly with Ruby
aid before queenie 6 and then Bishop d7
I have never seen such a perfect
sequence for Yasser to chip it no I
calculated when yessir is going to
appear that's my boy yes or no come on
Jen menu 50 mother wife we can make it
the lunar man you know we do commentary
on your games you realize right now in
the white camp
you're supposed to be able to defend any
position
[Music]
Yaya talks about this one previous game
a lot of work for me to do for most for
good moves that poor anymore alright
well the challenge is on block is
definitely up in this position as a pawn
and Queen but Brooks look terrible they
don't know where to go is they defending
the king and pawns look like they might
drop an h4 looking to create some
counter play Bobby what do you think
about your position I'm looking forward
to it he's not complicated enough for
the sync pills we are crossing got some
trouble no I mean seen how Rainey was
playing I'm not worried about this is
not
this is a tough situation right now now
it's chakra what are you thinking about
your position you don't seem convinced
it looks like black is is simply
dominated with Fabi is nothing right now
and Queen and Bishop getting the job
done it looks like it's getting soft I
see I see already how things like gonna
get from
[Laughter]
and f3 we just need to last 10 verse or
a few more booths and that's right here
it is as
[Music]
Gary this one's not easy to make five
moves they just wanted to make five more
moves to make it element a little bit
more random Gary's counting
[Music]
[Music]
Riga
winning position before I got in a very
bad 94/95 Yan said is not yes his fault
it's his nature not cool there well
there's a there's a lot of love going on
in this place but this means that team
Brandi is now ahead they're up by one
and it's going to be four more games but
there can be a comeback anything happens
in this competition so they're gonna
switch colors and now it's going to be
Randy with the white pieces and Rex with
the black pieces Rex you guys are down
right now
in the contest what are your feelings
about the situation it's not looking
great well I was given a reprieve I
didn't have to play five moves Kari
saved me well Randy you're ahead this is
a familiar position from last year
you're leading how do you feel about
that I just want to thank you sir again
for his contribution to my team I think
he's doing a great job
yes sir Randy is thanking you for the
contribution all right we're gonna
switch sides yet again in players now
black for Rex Randy with the white that
was a tough game that was a hard work
for it was a hard position to lose as we
saw white go down and yeah sir sir one's
gonna have to bounce back that's my guy
yeah sir
yeah so you gotta pick up those boobs I
will see how this goes we're gonna start
the third game I believe we're ready
hold on before we start let's get
everyone in places we're missing a few
players right now we see some of the
players Levon coming back in everybody
getting a little bit
Livan you're feeling good right now
absolutely it was a beautiful game and
you know it's kind of a game that
demoralizes the opponent so I think this
is going to be a smash Wow demoralize is
the word how are you guys feeling right
now they have been waiting like it's
also explanation from the man who was
the game yeah because he laughs and
that's before he could have resigned and
now you strike to pretend that you know
that it was not his fault
okay you say you won because he got such
a bad position yes a blunder some
serious words they're full of on you're
gonna prove something prove him wrong
Gary said you don't you blunder I mean
plays so far so all right we'll see you
ever heard from you yet how are you
feeling about the match I mean Randy's
playing while olive on came up with the
trickster or over-performing all right
well let's start and the handshake is in
and the game has a clocks have started
and d4 on the board score right now is
+1 to Randy's team and again we see g6
it's like Rex has prepared especially
for this match and we're and there we go
another Grunfeld
alright alright showing is all teammate
your team is actually so mean to each
other
yeah well you collected a bunch of mean
people what'd you expect
we thought we had all the trash talkers
on one side and they're trash-talking
each other so far doesn't seem like a
good leadership strategy for you Randy
builds confidence it brings out the best
in us that's that's what we need
[Applause]
this is embarrassing
taking some decision and now you make it
easy on versus wisely so right now in
what is a very rich position confused
probably clear it up for us what's
happening I'm not confused it looks
really good for again you also had some
some good input into the position you
know like the bishops for black pick it
on yeah so awfully hard right now yes
and we just we strike all the time
in high school you pick on the weakest
link
yeah we got some mean chest word I can't
see you picking on the weakest lady
whose shoes are you gonna protect your
assets
[Laughter]
my team is awfully confused I think some
of us need protection from our own team
all right well this position not going
on in this position right now
black trying to get some play p4p for
gains of space in the middle of the
board finally this was my long-term plan
is it all about you on each always trade
on c3 Bobby starting to sit down after
the move and a big decision f6
and f55 black breaking open the position
typical grünfeld style which is blocking
the bishops you know two bishops are not
good from the point has my that's a new
principal called the LaVon yes I don't
think he believes it he's thinking for
so long what do you think is thinking
about the move capture on e4 centralized
waiting for why this is that decision
assessment right now who's better well I
know that Knight has wandered around the
whole board neutralizing the two bishops
just learn a from LaVon
I figure out what that Mike was doing
overtime the sural you know cutting edge
life concepts that takes time jokes
aside actually we have a good night only
three and actually we are doing good so
there is some points to what all right
well this one is indeed very complex and
more Queen now going into b7 hitting
something scrumptious pause yes yes so
disease and b5 in response lots of sharp
decisions to make right now as it looks
like potential free pawn on d5
chakra comes to the board as the car was
collected upon white upon for the moment
Bishop sitting there and not accepting
the peace the sacrifice and now shock we
are having found this defense is now
penetrated to d3 look at the ninth is
going to decide the game and two more
moves before the Sinquefield sit down
correct
of course
oh and now we don't have six he's
bringing the Queen closer Kings
sometimes sometimes you can give in
check but not right now the Queen is
being challenged all that at six squared
Yassir comes has been called by yon
apology this is draw offer they can
repeat moves I think that it looks like
a repetition
[Laughter]
[Music]
there's a queen was a tremendous to pawn
looks like should be a draw but stranger
things have happened is now the sick
fields come to the board next four moves
will be critical for the Ziegfeld we're
waiting for you sir still thrashing or
for black to lose even of course but
they can torturous it's all about the
clock
should be a draw looks pretty even two
minutes though on the clock but they do
get the five-second increment so will be
very difficult to push them over on the
clock you just push everything for
forward until your opponent closes is
that a Giri principal yes all right
right now again looking quite drawn
all right yes sirs back in the chair
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
don't worry about that right now
guaranteed now very serious threat is
coming all right no Ruchi 7b come to the
training and King f7 so how to win this
position you know this is the problem
with the five-second increment you guys
can be sitting in forever trade routes
confident offer by Wesley and denied by
neck you can last forever
the time is not really a factor it's a
black is under a little bit of pressure
on the clock with only 48 seconds left
but it gaining five seconds on every
move what's the strategy for the winning
car I'm not sure that it is winning but
we'll try
for the next hour next hour remove 62 as
we speak always gets worse before it
gets better
this is our chance it's okay
[Applause]
now it looks like an extra might have
been played again therefore if I change
if I Kim is right
pawns being liquidated and I think that
we'll get an agreed wrong
[Music]
thankfully and finally and the score is
still plus one for Randi Sinquefield
as that rook in game just dissipated we
now have a lead by Randy over X is the
midpoint of the competition three games
done with three more to go
can team Rex come back and make this
into a contest so only plus one however
guys what was your feeling about that
game Magnus that seemed like it lasted
forever yeah we could have we made it a
lot harder on ourselves than we should
have but I feel like we missed a chance
at the end we could have won the pawn
and we could have won the game confident
swagger talked there as we're gonna
prepare for Game four look for somebody
or how are you feeling wish you felt
like you were winning that well at some
point they they allow does everything
and we had this pawn hit six we just had
to play a four but it is a look on h8 I
don't see a draw for black maybe I'm
wrong but I didn't see a blood draw for
black all right this is gonna demoralize
your team not winning this one no he's
still a point ahead
Bobby how are you feeling right now I
let it slip it was a bit disappointed
he's gonna do moralize the team no no I
mean they're just lucky to still be
alive in the match I think all right
well it looks like Randy is very intense
right now how you feeling man they're
they're playing some high-level moves
yeah it's it's hard to keep up I'm I
just want to make sure I stay focused
and follow the game but my team's
keeping me really confident you think
Rex is gonna crack under the pressure
that's what he's best at you know it's
amazing to see the Cinco Cop happened
here every single year it's now a
tradition in the seventh year you must
be proud of what the family has
accomplished your dad and your mom and
everything in the Chess Club it reminds
me of yesterday my buddy from LA I guess
he expends with the LA chess club and
they were all looking at the same field
cup book and watching it online so it's
really neat to see you know my my
hometown there repping the sinc fields
absolutely should be a ton of fun we're
gonna get to Game four in a moment Rex
you have the white pieces Randi with the
black pieces an intense moment because
it's only plus one very close match
right now and Rex what are you going to
do to make that comeback
well you know when you mess with the
best you die like the rest
that's cryptic Rex speak in English
there you go here we go we get the
seating arrangements set in we're at the
halfway point we're just past the
halfway point we're game four right now
and it looks like everybody's starting
to feel more relaxed they're into it one
seemed very confident team Randi
believing that they're gonna win this
one and team Rex needing a big victory
to make it all square so we're gonna
start the game question
they could just forfeit Rex don't worry
about them all right here we go and the
clock is starting and they're underway
Game four of ultimate moves so far a
repetition of Austin Boyd when he was
sitting here with the white pieces
madness he's copying you that's usually
flattery
[Laughter]
Yaser whipping out the moves there and
it's now the two Americans sitting down
to face off against each other Olympic
teammates in this one developing slowly
as we see difficult for white to get
anything immediately but a beep removed
they're shutting down action on the B
line I guess the bishops you want to go
to an end game of this day that's why
Wesley wants to give one more bishop and
go into the end game two bishops are
very strong if opponent has tonight
only one night but there's two twisters
everybody watching this book coming in
the future yes they're the kids of the
bishop's repetition they're kind of
bailing out the two players it looks
like he declined an offer is a secured
rule give it a boy
a bishop an eye for both sides according
to your principle you got nothing right
about this the side that you somehow
right now but in fact feeling the center
site that used to have two bishops keeps
the advantage when your listen to LaVon
very carefully who write you forward
using this is the night is too far
see one more piece joins the the sensor
I mean now everything is slowly getting
there last call was actually very
beautiful you're appreciating their
moves yes well that was a good defensive
move we were really getting a grip on
the light squares Gary's coming in there
was an involuntary scream there either
leaves the center while Paul leaves the
center why greed right here black
blackest triple pars double pronged
isolate where's our the worst structure
black has ever gotten in any game ever
played yeah we should always you know
where we have anything for anything
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
all right
all right an intriguing position I think
all these top lawyers are fascinated of
what is really going on here
and only 51 seconds 46 seconds so you
can get some all right only 30 seconds
your ex is sitting down now and
I mean so much worse Randy collecting
yet another pawn
three blocks up right now two more moves
for black to play
actually it's as a three more moves to
more Musa by four pawns up extra pose do
we have it's crazy it doesn't matter
[Applause]
a change in the position of gigantic
change
[Applause]
[Music]
for
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right they're gonna get a minute you
guys got to resign Mike will resign yes
all right resignation up a rock anyway
all right well that ties it up now so
feeling good I had to bring this back
you know we were on the brink we were on
the brink of the defeat that ties it up
it is now what theis core to 2 is the
score I believe yes after four games
Randy rookies two in a winning position
that was rough
it was brutal I had plenty of time I
just felt nervous should have taken my
time
I don't know I don't know what it's
thinking you got to come back from that
one and tough one
indeed Rex you're all tied up your let's
get Rex's opinion Rex you're all tied up
after what looked like a tough game but
Randy donated a room he Randy gave me a
great gift he's being a good son is it
your birthday when is your birthday is
this soon an acceptance or early
birthday present from yourself
all right well that tied things up now
it's 2-2 only two more games left we're
gonna go to game five in a very close
match clearly Yassir is very happy right
now yeah so you're flexing you're
feeling good well it's two to two I
think we have some disappointed players
some happy ones indeed it seemed like
the rightful score as the players get
ready Rex already in his chair Randy's
gonna have to get himself back we're
going to look a little bit of coaching
here from Levon what are you gonna tell
Randy an itch made it very difficult for
Randy to play that position because it
was so complicated so I won't put so
much blame on Randy you're blaming
Anisha yes you're blaming your team a
very very toxic position for Randy so
how you guys gonna settle it down and
come back from this one we should just
tell Anish to to understand his role and
understand the team play and you know
then we'll move from there well are you
gonna do it yourself you're gonna have
Randy do it Randy's delivered the final
blow all right okay Wow there seems to
be some kind of internal issues on the
teams but they'll work that out as we go
to game 5 white is Randy looking to make
a comeback from the last game Rex with
black and it is tied a 2-2 game 5 the
penultimate round and now they've
started the clock and the game has begun
well clock issue they're restarting
because they started the clock with no
clock not properly up and now who played
whisper just making final adjustments
there as d4 will be plays when to start
the clock and there we go and it looks
like we're gonna see for the third time
the same opening no variances I think
both sides like their position game is
afoot who's coming up next the caller
will be sitting down and we see a
grünfeld for the third time in the
capture on d5 and Rex has just castled
unfortunately a mix-up of the move order
and they're down upon to start the game
is blind neither player was to come in
and blind
Leslie you've entered down the pond
already well we'll never give up big
affair later we know Randy will come
back Grantham's
I always sacrifice upon all right down
upon is black erection you didn't take
the pong why did you take all right
giving your son an early birthday gift
what is his birthday Wow we're in a wild
one has more pawn sacrifices I'm playing
for the position I just wanted to show
my you know that should hopes in his own
all right well now
[Laughter]
[Music]
now
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
giving Indian school of crab in this
position those great decisions in which
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
despite the results of this and our
capture
[Music]
wasting time there is only one 42 this
last to move getting dementia back I was
thinking
Queeny 3x and then rookie castle [ __ ]
basics used to be three two pawns or may
be unclean to pause but right now only
up one and the key start in the middle
of the 40 we under attack right now as
the bishop Queen - III and now it is
maxime this I do see five of my in the
opening
very good is the team with white at the
moment at the moment but with the king
in the
[Laughter]
we're talking say one of my recipes the
moment has come now very moment of
silence okay for imposition nice
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay you make it
winning by cleanings so enjoyable
[Laughter]
lost position can he make any tricks
it's Bobby versus yessir
I am going to take on the sins of our
team
[Music]
[Applause]
cleans up the board big-time result
Randy's team takes back the lead they're
up won five games done one more to go
ken retches team tied up big game coming
up the final game in the competition as
this has been going back and forth like
a heavyweight fight in the stakes
they're happening and I playing perfect
moves but who knows what's gonna happen
in Game six Rex you guys are in a tough
position right now you've lost one more
you're down one you've got to win and
what do you do win simple where's Randy
we get a little discussion happening
right now we're strategy here hikaru
helped me in the opening preparation
last game and it proved to be really
helpful especially with my dad's blunder
early on are you feeling confident now
you guys just have to close it out we're
going for the win wins as well
Game six the final game about to begin
and is everyone on the right side all
right folks get grasses get to your
positions please
the final game team Rex over on this
side of the room team Randy
Gary talk to us how you feeling right
now one point handicap was too much so
we just proofs that so they they managed
to win and do more we were lost that
move five I think it just you know the
fact we put up great fight so ready tell
us how good is our team is now we've
seen magnets win on the man in the last
round you guys have to win on the man
now give us some world championship
advice and these games happen so let's
see I can give you more you know just of
an update after four five moves all
right they've been pretty well are the
first five most though hopefully if we
get the same position maybe now we'll
we'll deliver it it's a pity I mean is
the game to was just ruinous because
will completely winning okay I don't
want to blame yes sir but we have to
blame yes sir okay Game six is up and on
and it's time to start the final game
handshake in start the clock
and here we go and it looks like we're
gonna revisit that brillo pads we've
been seeing
we descend all
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
know what to do
[Music]
[Laughter]
you know forget things I can live with
myself not attention right now a lot of
time on the clock however but again
[Music]
[Music]
trying to figure out what he's trying to
do anyone's the game
[Laughter]
long think by Maxine yes I square and
thinking about those blocks history
process
[Laughter]
this is being traded off in a draw suits
blah they win the match seem to be much
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
and about you reporting the facts by
Gary is you know yes to win this game no
but he wants an end
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
Magnus with h4
our position improved tremendously
thinks that is March of the h-bomb being
starts this month again not again the
squeeze
a pseudo sacrifice in our work on d3
Black is threatening to take over the
game
I can see that these guys have learned
something from my games slowly take all
right a challenge on the last move for
den Lorraine and he's down to one minute
and once I can make that now under a
minute it has to be the hero now
[Laughter]
[Music]
Joe wins for the black squad for the
darks one night I was right going away
this game
it's very critical moment in the game
the sing fields have come in they
brought in the cleanup squad we'll see
what happens now only 13 seconds left
for Rex now 17 Randy with a full 217 on
the clock
seven seconds left
[Music]
has been called illegal minutes
[Music]
[Music]
to close it out one more move a
checkmate and Randy Singh field takes
down his his father this time with the
maid on the board team Randy wins it the
MVP Randy how you feeling oh man I feel
so much better coming back from that
game for blunder I got it thank these
guys so much I've had so much coaching
the karu LaVon everyone make me feel
comfortable talking trash making it fun
oh what a relief
Rex your son takes you down for the
second year in a row how does it feel I
think that my GM's are gonna hang me I
doubt it I think everybody is quite
pleased with it LaVon from the winning
team's final word I think it was a fair
match I think the team was doing very
well but more it's it's Randy's doing I
mean he played some excellent excellent
moves what about you sir yes we have to
thank Randy and yes sir for their
contributions to our success I'll have
you close it out as my fellow
commentator there is a god and he hates
our guts these guys were so lucky
Maurice I just can't even begin to
express it we're gonna do more training
Rex and I are gonna do some more
training for next year for a next year
well but for this year team Randy wins
it by a score of 4 to 2 and we will have
more chess of course it's not over first
of all the closing ceremony tonight will
be live at 6:30 Central Time and then
next week it will be Garry Kasparov in
the building as we're going to do
chess960 make sure you check our website
for all the action but for now we're
gonna close it out as team Randy does
the job yet again see you next time
[Music]